[Applause]
there's a desert jewel that had the
world talking and in the end redemption
for Antony Joshua he had stared down a
career-ending abyss but came out
fighting smarter than before an ear
punch perfect display to be Andrea jr.
in their heavyweight rematch and these
four title belts and his reputation are
restored
I want to thank God I want to say
bismillah next I want to say man the
first time was so nice I had to do it
twice Bruce jr. has made no secret of
his love of chocolate bars
he gained a stone in weight for this
fight and it showed you know what it
kind of picked me a lot I thought I was
gonna feel stronger out that I was gonna
be better but you know what I think next
fight I'm gonna get more prepared I'm
gonna work with my team a little bit
more
Joshua landed the right hook in the
first round which left Tory's jr.
bleeding throughout he danced around the
Mexican American who had slowed
significantly since the pair last met in
New York June and there was no doubt who
was the victor here this was the biggest
sporting event in Saudi Arabia's history
and nearly 15,000 Pat's the Duryea arena
Saudi Arabia is a new frontier for world
boxing and in some ways this is a
country changing drastically very
quickly until 2018 women weren't allowed
in stadiums on a company everything is
changing like
the life of the women here is changing
way too fast like I still can't
comprehend how amazing this is you know
a few thousand British bands also
traveled here to see Joshua become a
two-time heavyweight world champion but
amazingly today keep that keep him at
distance and did well the performance
you've ever seen I would say so clinical
clinical yeah look like a bit of
Muhammad Ali in there dancing around
awesome absolutely amazing great venue
great fight so good so happy for AJ's
well first time since all questions will
continue to be asked about holding an
event at this magnitude in a country
with such an appalling human rights
record but as far as boxing is concerned
Anthony Joshua has finally answered the
doubters Martha Kellner
Sky News Saudi Arabia